alles lug nachdem ich heute schon ein
neues instagram bild und eine neue
podcast folge hochgeladen habe darf ich
euch jetzt auch hier herzlich willkommen
heißt und seiner neuen funktion zehn
minuten dummheit mit eurem schwachsinns
apparat luca heute bin ich allerdings
kein richtiger schwachsinns apparat
sondern eine schwachsinns taube das bin
ich und ich flieg don't know how to lend
ich will nicht als schwierig also diese
kleine taube hier sind auf jeden fall
wir und unser ziel in diesem spiel
sollte es sein dass wir so viele leute
wie
dem auf jeden fall
ziele in diesem spiel und zwar müssen
wir beispielsweise leute an
ja das war es dann auch schon bevor wir
allerdings können müssen wir erstmal
etwas finden was riecht irgendwie kann
ich immer noch nicht richtig landen
ich esse jetzt erstmal hier so ein
bisschen vergammelten ok unser magen hat
sich müssen aufgefüllt ich würde sagen
wir packen jetzt erstmal die tauben
zwischen rhein dadurch können wir
nämlich direkt sehen aha okay wir unten
haben wir noch mehr essen
ich lerne jetzt mal ganz sanft
das hat super geklappt ein paar sekunden
später hey hey was schlägt er mich
darunter ich will doch nur hier
hey was schlägst du mich war es ist doch
völlig normal dass die tore einfach
degas ist es dein ernst lasst mich doch
dieses verdammte sender nicht eine taube
sehe würde ich dir auch nicht einfach
schlagen
ich würde ihnen die verscheuchen wollen
aber wer steckt damit wir packen jetzt
einfach direkt die bird wünschen rein
und fliegen hier vorne direkt hin
so aber gut okay wenn die mich nicht da
ab
der ist anscheinend tot dann erstmal
seinen downloads den hier vorne können
wir den auch irgendwie umnieten warten
im moment ganz langsam ganz langsam ganz
langsam jetzt runter und eigentlich will
ich den typen töten stattdessen habe ich
dahin gekackt sie verstecken sich
allerdings alle das heißt ich kann jetzt
einmal ganz gediegen hier auf den tisch
draufgehen
wie gehen
springt dann kann ich ihn
[Musik]
ich muss doch irgendwie auf dem
da kann ich nicht geschehen wie darauf
moment ganz langsam ganz langsam
beruhigt
das ist ein ganz normales spiel wir
müssen allerdings nicht nur zum essen
kümmern sondern hier packt mal die world
vision rein wir müssen uns auch um einen
lässt kümmern da wenn wir sterben werden
wir da quasi wiederbelebt julia star
wegen okay verdammte axt ich schau mal
was ist hier gibt's hier nicht dass auch
hier von goalie ach das ist ein stick da
ich brauche aber kein stick mein gott
ich muss etwas zu fressen kriegen da
vorne steht ja auch gegen jeden baum den
serien gibt so ganz langsam
ok
wir gehen ganz langsam jetzt vor
okay ich habe das irgendwie machen wir
das gleiche jetzt mal wieder ich lande
hier
ich lande ich hab' ich gerade schon
wieder gekappt mich zu da mal landen
[Musik]
ich schwöre jetzt hier den turbo mode
rein also wir schauen uns direkt ein
nest an damit sie nicht schon wieder
direkt von beginn an sterben also hier
vorne ist ein es okay dass ein stück ab
stocker da unten da hinten liegende
menge stöcker also hier unter den bäumen
das ist natürlich auch logisch von na ja
jetzt langsam dahin langsam genau wir
landen
sehr schön in 1 gelandet wir landen wir
landen peter peters gelandet wir nehmen
jetzt hier einen stick damit man nämlich
einfach
aber okay wir haben einen stick los
gehts meine gab mein kontakt bevor wir
uns weiter um unser netz kümmern würde
ich sagen gehen wir erstmal hier drauf
und können
okay das sollen uns trotzdem gönnt jetzt
können wir noch ein bisschen futter und
dann aber auf jeden fall komplettes
leben was wir rechts eingeblendet sehen
müssen uns allerdings weiteren sticks
kümmern ich sehe schon mit word vision
da unten liegt noch ein stick von 1 ganz
langsam so wundervoll hey peter du
machst du bist ja richtig gut
ja
das ist mein nest wir brauchen noch
einen letzten stock glaube ich dann ist
unser netz fertig von daher nehme ich
jetzt mal hier vorne den fetten stock da
da sehr gute landung peter heger
pd london peter ich rufe die beta
anhänger gepackt dann bist du denn zu
blöd zum landen peter h ok sehr gut okay
die kamera hier umändern fliegen mal
wieder davon
oh mein gott ich fliege ja als würde ich
jetzt 70 kölsch intus haben ganz langsam
peter da unser netz ist fertig unser
netz zu bilden was bedeutet das jetzt
wir haben auf jeden fall unser nest
jetzt hier fertig war hat unser hat
unser leistungs rad geschlagen
da
jj chicks nied foodwatch ich bin
wir bringen peter jetzt um uns
verlangten wir jetzt einfach mal auf
diesen komischen schornstein hier oben
drauf und jetzt peter würde ich sagen
fällt für einfach mal runter
mein leben ist voll und ich sterbe wenn
wenn ich mein nest berühre oder was zu
beginn habe ich das schwer geliebt jetzt
rate ich bei mir sowieso nie so tief und
so bin ich
peter mitterbauer schiffs zum in der
band von einem lkw
hallo komm raus aus den eltern gehabt
man das kann nicht so schwer sein die
hauptsache
das kriegst du hast da bin ja das geht
ja gar nicht übrig alle tester beim
computer ran
das kann doch nicht so schwer sein mit
diesem dreck vogel hier mein gott ok
kommen wir orientieren uns jetzt mal in
richtung das hier vorne da gab es ein
lecker lecker dollar zu beginnen will
ich allerdings sagen nehmen wir stellen
uns erstmal damit ist es dein ernst
peter du kommst dem bürgersteig nicht
ich kann mein fehler ich weiß nicht dass
man springen kann
lecker also ein bisschen abgelaufen das
fressen hier
wir schauen jetzt mal hier vorne in den
laden rein vielleicht können uns ja auch
direkt
dann schauen wir halt nicht in den laden
reinen die haben wir noch ein bisschen
vergammelte chicken mcnuggets super hier
haben wir noch so einen becher milch
sehr gut sehr kurzer aber davor
da gibt's besseres essen ist hier gerade
stoppt haben sondern was macht der
anbieter sieht auch überhaupt nicht aus
gerade er hat doch auf mich zu schlagen
frisch gestärkt wenn man jetzt sagen wir
machen mal so nein
oh doch was zu trinken ich habe mich
einfach gefragt ich kann ja es stöcker
hochheben und ich kann ja auch essen
hochheben
wir hatten ja zu beginnen so einen
brezel dingen geklaut einem kann ich
auch menschen kann ich kann ich menschen
hochheben nur wenige minuten später
ich stehe auf den menschen
auf hold ab
jetzt
ich hasse dich
die einen allerletzten versuch hier von
mir kriegst du noch und jetzt strecken
bei uns mal richtig an also word vision
an die menschen hier menschen die
brauchen allerdings keine menschen
sondern wir müssen ein nest bauen und
dafür brauchen wir stärker wurden
stöcker
wir sind keine rassisten
das essen
da dazu ich will einfach nur jetzt
ich zeig dich an
es war nicht mal was ich schilder nur
ich habe so heißt das ist das ja ich
verstecke mich jetzt einfach dir
zwischen da kann ich keinem etwas antun
kein mensch kann ihnen die böse auf mich
sein ich schaue mir jetzt mal das
tierchen ab das ist nicht dein ernst
das ist nicht sein ernst nicht mehr du
kommst
der kommt jetzt wirklich von der anderen
seite wieder oder was ist da
ist das neue spiele oder wasser wieder
[Musik]
an der stelle ich das heute wieder soll
es aber hätten meine lieben freunde mein
herz mein kreislauf macht es einfach
nicht mehr mit zu sehen wie eine
unschuldige taube namen speed up against
me later mit mir luca und der taube
liter gefallen hat dann zeigst mir gern
mit einem daumen hoch und ein video hier
schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare ob
ihr bock auf einen zweiten teil von
hättet und hier findet ihr jetzt ein
smiley eingeblendet wenn er darauf legen
könnte meinen kanal abonnieren ist mega
cool weil es kostenlos ist und dann
verpasst ihr solche wundervollen video
meisterwerke wie das hier in zukunft
nicht mehr und bekommt die videos direkt
angezeigt ist das mega cool und tier ist
ein anderes video verlinkt könnt ihr
euch gerne angucken weil wir haben alle
grad nichts zu tun an der zeit gerade